♪ ♪
>> Greg: SO BOYS AND GIRLS,
HERE’S A LITTLE SECRET TO
GETTING MORE PRESENTS FOR
CHRISTMAS THEN YOU CAN EVER
IMAGINE.
ASK FOR ONE FROM A POLITICALLY
CORRECT SHOPPING MALL AND FILM
THE RESPONSE.
>> NO GUNS.
>> A NERF GUN?
>> NOT EVEN A NERF GUN.
IF YOUR DAD WANTS TO GET IT FOR
YOU THAT’S FINE BUT I CAN’T
BRING IT TO YOU.
WHAT ELSE, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Greg: TO BE CLEAR TO THE
KIDS WATCHING AT HOME, THAT WAS
NOT THE REAL SANTA, THE REAL
SANTA GOT A COLD AND DIDN’T WANT
TO SPREAD IT TO THE KID SO SANTA
TRUSTED THE SHOPPING MALL TO
FIND A REASONABLE SUBSTITUTE.
THE PROBLEM WAS IT WAS ON SHORT
NOTICE AND THEY ENDED UP WITH
THIS FELLA WHO SPREADS CHRISTMAS
CHEER THE WAY I SPREAD SOBRIETY.
NOT WELL.
SORRY, DUDE, THE LITTLE BOY
DIDN’T ASK FOR AN AK-47, HE
ASKED FOR A TOY NERF GUN AND IF
YOU CAN’T TELL THE DIFFERENCE
YOU DESERVE TO GET STUCK IN A
CHIMNEY BEHIND JOY BEHAR.
THANK GOD HE DIDN’T ASK FOR A
G.I. JOE OR A GAS GUZZLING HOT
WHEELS OR MAY BE AN ELF A SHELF.
HERE’S THE GOOD NEWS.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE HAVE LIKELY
SEEN THIS PC SANTA THAT REDUCE
THE BOY TO TEARS WHICH MEANS
GIVEN THAT THIS IS AMERICA THE
GREATEST, MOST GENEROUS COUNTRY
ON EARTH YOU CAN BET THAT LITTLE
TYKE GOT MORE NERF GUNS THAT THE
PORTLAND POLICE DEPARTMENT HAS
WHO ARE ONLY ALLOWED NERF GUNS.
MAYBE THE REAL SANTA WILL PAY
HIM A VISIT.
>> WE ARE SO SORRY ABOUT THAT.
>> Greg: AS FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE
ANTIVENOM OF THE VIDEO WENT
AROUND THE WORLD FASTER THAN
DONOR A BLITZ IN WHICH MEANS
HE’S GETTING FOR CHRISTMAS IS
COLE ALSO DELIVERED BY THE REAL
SANTA.
YOU WILL KNOW IT’S HIM BECAUSE
OF THE HUGE CARBON FOOTPRINT.
ALL RIGHT, DAY AGAIN.
I’M GOING TO SAY ONE THING IN
DEFENSE OF THE SHOPPING MALL
SANTA, IT MIGHT’VE BEEN A
POLICY.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN A POLICY AT
THE MALL.
WHO KNOWS.
>> Dagen: IT WOULDN’T HAVE
BEEN A POLICY AT THE MALL AND
THAT MOTHER HAD AN INFANT, SHE
HAD TO PUT THE INFANT DOWN.
IF I I HAD BEEN A BYSTANDER I
WOULD’VE TAKEN A DIVE ACROSS
THAT DESK AND BROKEN HIS THAT
GLASSES.
WE’VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT NERF
PRODUCT SINCE WE WERE LIKE FOUR.
>> Jesse: I ASKED MY PARENTS
FOR A NERF GUN FOR CHRISTMAS AND
THEY SAID NO BECAUSE THEY ARE
FAR LEFT.
AND LOOK HOW I TURNED OUT.
I’M A FOX HOST, MOM.
THAT BACKFIRED, DIDN’T IT?
I HEARD YOUR MONOLOGUE, WHEN I
HEARD THIS TODAY THE FIRST THING
I DID WAS LOOK UP HOW MUCH MALL
SANTA’S MAKE, OBVIOUSLY AND THEY
MAKE BETWEEN $30.100 AN HOUR SO
IN DECEMBER THEY CAN CLEAR 5-10
GRAND.
IF I’M GETTING PAID 5-10 GRAND
TO SIT THERE THAT KID CAN ASK
FOR ANTHRAX.
WHATEVER YOU WANT, KIDDO.
>> Greg: I THINK THAT WAS A
REJECTED REINDEER NAME.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
ANY SYMPATHY FOR THE SANTA?
>> Geraldo: EVER SINCE THE
BILLY BOB THORTON MOVIE "BAD
SANTA" WHERE HE PLAYED DRUNK AND
REPROBATE SANTA I CAN’T GET INTO
SANTA ANYMORE.
I WOULDN’T LET ANY SMALL CHILD
RELATED TO ME, WHO KNOWS WHAT’S
IN THOSE.
>> Greg: I WAS A SHOPPING MALL
SANTA.
YOU’VE HEARD THIS, DAY AGAIN.
I WAS REPRIMANDED FOR DRINKING
WINE AT LUNCHTIME.
DANA, YOU ARE MORE LIKE A SMURF
THAN A NERF.
>> Dana: I THINK THE SHOCKING
NEWS HERE IS THAT YOU ARE A